um title of my talk as you I assume are
still literate its phrasing
communicating data science through gifts
tweets and classic misdirection if you
haven't seen Archer you can take a nap
or whatever yeah so my name is Mark Eric
I am the tidy versed dev advocate at our
studio I'm not a real data scientist and
I my job description is you know gruff
but lovable driver mechanic and an
occasional muscle yeah so if you know me
at all it's probably because I go on
Twitter I would say tweeting is now
maybe only like 90% of what I do but
down since I first made these slides so
yeah this wasn't the only option for
titles for this talk is that a reference
I should get are you all just saying
random words and the reasoning behind
this is because this is like kind of how
I feel operating in life in general and
certainly in the data science realm and
in fact I like to say that I am a data
scientist which means a superficial
pretender to knowledge luckily in
college I majored in science and society
which means I know everything about both
of those things now it's called science
and technology studies so if nothing
more I'm actually a very well trained
sayest ya the origin story basketball
so I actually first started using are
like 2001-2002 for fantasy basketball
because I was really cool in high school
yes so I was really into fantasy
basketball and being like sixteen or
whatever I randomly found like an
open-source programming language so I
could win my league fast forward to a
few years back and they banned our in
that league luckily I can do some pipe I
please let's now that's keeping me back
the bat pick yeah if you can see here
I've got this sticker of my dog the bat
Pig yes so I was gonna like immobilizer
for like two years
gotten a skateboarding accident and my
dog got like Twitter famous like ten
years ago he's really big in Japan and
so while I was in a leg immobilizer man
she's my dog social media account I
started to you know learn a little bit
of programming here and there dive into
who knows what and I used this thing
called buffer so that looking at
pictures of cute dogs didn't just take
over my life to schedule my posts I they
don't have like an affiliate program but
if they did I should be getting cash
yeah and also because again the Japanese
time zone things so that was kind of how
I like learned learned the Twitter as my
mom calls it but when it comes to our
it's more kind of just like me learning
out loud like oMG I just learned a thing
and that's okay I so it's funny to me
that my Twitter feed is useful to other
people because really it was just a way
of me keeping track of the things that I
was reading and learning and then making
sure that I didn't try to read all the
things so I'd be like oh if I just read
I won't post anything I haven't read so
if I just do five a day that seems like
a healthy limit sometimes I go over
yeah so that was kind of what started my
tweeting deal 100% selfish remains true
but it turns out that I I guess this was
useful to other people
happily thought it was and this is like
pre bow tie photo so pretty Oh G right
there
yeah I was taken aback also really he
followed this up by saying who so he
didn't have to keep retweeting me so
it's laziness on his part yeah and I
know real data scientists are in the
room so we've got some empirical
evidence that yeah I am in fact the key
to a successful blog post for Edwin
Fallon yeah so uh my inference they're
actually an overlap between things that
are selfish and things that are useful
to other people thank God hello Anushka
Sharma yes we can be LinkedIn friends
I'm gonna accept that later don't take
it personally
yeah and you might have noticed that
slight non-technical burn and Hadley
then like followed up with this but then
before I gave my first talk he's like Oh
like you know just let people know you
don't have to be the greatest scientist
to contribute so he kind of back pedaled
this one but ya know Lucy who could not
be here today I think put it best you
know she was saying like okay the way I
read this is that if you're non tech
she's a fire go to two dancing girls
trophy emoji and like my line here was
like a be the fire two dancing girls
trophy emoji you want to see in the
world but then somebody replied to that
with saying be the two girls one cup you
want to see in the world and totally
ruined it so farewell to this slide yeah
but so I'm really into words a yeah so
there there is a word for that it's
called exoteric yes james long keeping
it yeah yeah thanks linkedin yes so uh i
am a bit of an EXO terrorist or yeah
that's my jam why because a lot of times
in reading things and they are half in
English and half in squiggly i actually
made that first when i opened at apology
book and somebody replied back being
like they're called contour lines
that's typography don't post apology
jokes on immature lesson learned
yeah so yeah you might think that this
is me engaging in it bit of aporia it's
not i am still surprised by the fact
that people find what i do useful
hypotheses woo oh how are we not already
connected yeah so um
my efforts are not always tidy in fact a
lot of times it's you know but like
Jenny Brian calls it data rectangle for
me it's like idea rectangle so yeah I
have a lot of untidy efforts I'll be a
tidy handwriting do not use that syntax
anymore but yeah so like my working
hypothesis here is like I think people
kind of like seeing that thoughts don't
always fit in data frames like a
literally please do not submit all of
your pull request like this but like
sometimes words are not that useful and
I have to like draw on things and put
emoji there and maybe people jam with
that I also post a lot of other people's
content so that's like hypothesis number
two is that people like seeing that
maybe but and here's where there's like
a real newcomer pitch it's not
necessarily new novelty is a little
overrated
Hilary Parker's like guide to package
writing remains fire emoji and so it's a
lot of content that like you wouldn't be
reading it if you already knew how to do
it and I guarantee you that if you're
learning how to do something somebody
else is also probably learning how to do
it so you know give it a shout or not
that's like my last type obviousness
yeah so outcomes where did this get me
well I got to partner with Elijah Meeks
making a visualization of the entire
corpus of Archer which we did code by
hand and Elijah is actually the head of
data visualization at Netflix and also
valuable if not unbearably so I ended up
analyzing it using tidy text so like
real data scientists or whatever like D
Rob
and Julia who write books or like oh can
you review this and I did I also got
involved with our open side which is an
awesome organization I they invited me
to their uncommon I did like a video
chat and I the first thing he said I was
like I don't know C++ and it turned out
that was okay and they also have this
awesome package review process I was
really worried that like all I was gonna
have to say I was like yes this is a
package it turned out it was so I did
say that but it also turns out that like
they knew I wasn't gonna you know make
it more performant or who knows you know
like experts actually need newcomers so
my feedback was like oh all of this
warning coming up every five seconds is
really scary two hypothetical newcomer
so uh let's get into tradecraft this is
the anatomy of a tweet that's not me uh
yeah like cool tutorial using package
name title author handle relevant hash
tag it's like kind of how I roll
and again because I'm selfish I take a
lot of pictures screenshots whatever so
this is like a tweet where I'm talking
about something and here's what I think
people actually see it's like oh like I
need that cluster II bubble thing and
that's why they look at it and it's
useful to them yeah and unsubstantiated
hypothesis I he here attribution I treat
my future self like I will have a
traumatic brain injury at any given time
this is reflected in my code comments
and throughout my life including like my
code comments to self on post-its yeah
so I put attribution on everything I
think people like that and the tweet
itself is not the content
so Jenny Brian makes awesome
presentation
that are breat unto themselves and then
I put them together and like ruin them
into collages so that I can find what I
need again and this is helpful of other
people I guess yeah like people like to
read pretty minimally so if you can
break it down to like hieroglyphs
they're into it yeah so like my tweet
ARS reader run I maybe some people tweet
things they don't read that would make
me incredibly nervous I also never
didn't like always with the reading for
class and so maybe that's not totally or
whatever relatable my retrievable that's
what the pictures are for again
selfishly so I can find whatever it is I
was just reading again it's a lot easier
to find like a picture of a giant
paperclip than it is to find a word
relevant again kind of matte and real
you do you to dancing girls
explosion tada if tweeting is not your
thing don't do it I what I do is not for
everyone I have a pretty big fan club
over in Stack Overflow art chat and I'll
swear that our finance conferences they
may be renaming at them are a pretend
Club likely Hadley Wickham fan club but
anyway so yeah like do your own thing
and the my favorite feature of Twitter
is mute own it and use it liberally so
is this all just classic misdirection
kinda I guess in a weird way this is me
contributing to open source and now I've
contributed in some other ways too but
you know what if this helps other people
learn things and they don't have to ask
like Hadley or Jim Hester Gabor max
about it then and they can like build
out a sweet package well I'm telling
somebody where a tutorial is then I
consider that a contribution in its own
right because I want whatever sweet
feature that writing and then I have
this whole analogy about a Portuguese
man-of-war turns out people are not as
into invertebrate zoology as I am so it
doesn't really work but yeah so great
book opened advice about what holds
people back from contributing to open
source can't break code I'm not really
good at this I just be a burden they
already have people who are smarter than
me I've never thought any of these
things I'm kidding my first big big
contribution was in our per data science
for those of you can't see there was
almost four R's in one of the mentions
of her as a result my dog's name ended
up in the acknowledgement section of our
for data science but I was talking about
this yesterday
nobody wants a typo in there both and/or
package and/or code and/or life unless
the pun in which case keep it so again
like go for it fix typos another good
diagram that's not about data scientists
turns out that confusion and
contribution also overlap you don't have
to wait to be like done I'm not a
finished product yet just ask my parents
but that doesn't mean that there's no
way for me to contribute in my own like
weird learning Yee excited way and you
never know when what you're doing is
gonna be helpful to someone else so yeah
Hadley mentioned this really cool
package that works with shiny called
pool and being helpful and a major
contributor like I am I responded with
an archer guess to the surprise of no
one but turned out that yeah if it
weren't for that gift Matt Dickinson
never would have found the package he
needed
who's laughing now phrasing boom
inappropriate yes so thank you in
addition to Pam and Katya to all these
people who let me like mess with their
packages and been like hired me they may
be regretting that now but and thanks
Jared for having me um all these like
real data scientists up here have been
really great and yeah so that's my jam
and danger zone oh yeah whoever that was
you too
[Applause]
you